hello everybody.welcome stream
quarterback we're back we missed you
it's been a month right bad it's been a
frickin month and I were coming back
hard with this shirt you were a nice
shirt today thank you and dream daddy a
dad dating simulator now here's the
thing one of my friends Dave works at a
place and he was saying at his place of
business play a lot of video games our
lunch break and everybody's playing this
game everybody's talking about it how
can you not it's a dad dating simulator
you know what I'm saying how can you not
it's it's amazing yeah
dream daddy it's the best all right we
got some dad first of all let's just
talk very quick before we get into this
game I want to talk about this song
which is amazing this game is made by
game grumps and game grumps you guys
nailed this tune I love this is amazing
I just love this song I want to live in
the world that this song promises us
yeah it's great
I'll wear my first hot dad shirt this is
kind of a hot dad shirt you know that's
right exactly Oh Mouse could you put the
chat up at some point oh my man and yeah
so it's very exciting I and and I mean
we should maybe just get into playing
will dream daddy we haven't seen you
guys we did that we did a bunch of live
pre shows with our pals Moses Storm and
Chris red it was great very exciting all
limits all of it very exciting I don't
want to really click to continue because
I want to keep listening this song but I
think we have to continue so let's just
get into it man I love all these dad
tips oh here we go also but this is like
a chooser an adventure game so you're
gonna help you're gonna help me be the
best dad be the best dad there is
exactly so yeah we're sleeping we're
sleeping that's right oh no what is this
wake up pretend to be dead five more
minutes
five more minutes that's
you said that five minutes ago dad and
also ten minutes ago ah there's our
daughter we're spooning a moving box
alrighty stuffs getting a little sexy
which I like I want things to go
very sexy it's Wednesday guys it's hump
day and I think it's it's called that
not just cuz it's the middle of the week
if you get my meat in here to get my
meaning
that's for humping boxes okay yawn and
stretch morning Amanda panda I think her
name's Amanda
yikes dad breath go brush your teeth
alright so so far we're a dad who's just
woken up yeah building that dad alright
so here we go first of all the most
important part of every dad the dad bod
yeah right the dad but um yes so what
kind of bond we want here guys I've got
a big dad bod got it a skinny dad bod
also we're in boxer briefs which I like
because they don't ride up you know but
they're also not loosey-goosey exactly
pretty exciting hell mouths you want to
put that at the lower left if you would
my friend uh there's kind of a normal
dad bod although a good a good you know
like we're toned and we're muscular kind
of bigger dad vibes yeah I don't know
what the difference is oh the hair oh
look the hair is different so this dude
shaves his pits but he has arms arm hair
this guy bless our hair but pity your
pits that's the difference we needs two
guys - oh yeah look at this oh look it's
the body hair okay so this is more of
like a I got it okay first of all okay I
think first of all do we got a hairy
dead or not hairy dead
everyone in Jet Harry - Harry dad or
less Harry dead man bare belly we want
me like a big dad bought Claire Johnson
what's going on hey Magic Man Gingras
yeah we do we have bottom rope dance is
supposed to represent Oh
that true transgender dance is the
bottom row really ha all right
great I'm in alright so what do we want
when Harry no hair dad I'm seeing Harry
Harry I see a lot of Harry's bond Row is
trans people are saying ok great so I
think we got everybody is saying Harry
so we're gonna go Harry we're gonna go
top now will I kind of let go of the big
bad bot I do bear style what do you guys
think bear style Harry boy Harry belly
up I'm seeing some belly right why not
make it look like Conan I don't know
that's no fun come on really thick dad
Harry big Harry dad big ya Pig yeah big
beautiful fee I've definitely barely
Cosette okay great we got the dead body
now heads now this is important what are
we doing here at different heads it's
very subtle no I don't want the Ed
Harris chiseled look I'm not a big no
what do you think Beth these are all
kind it's very subtle I mean I like a
jawline you love your thick dad bear dad
we're making a bear dad we're not gonna
make Conan that's boring come on guys
I do like a jawline I don't want I don't
want some kind of jolly dad I want look
good square seems to fit right all right
let's do like a square yeah right this
looks pretty good I think
all right shadow or no shadow is the
question yeah I kind of like a clean up
more of a clean cut dad dad is like a
drinker yeah this dad's a drink yes this
is a drinker we want to be a good dad we
want to be a good dad
yes crop boy Beth is here Jason O'Malley
creeper in the corner roundish square
head
mostly harvest is saying no for no
reason squares good okay good all right
no shadow no shadow hair now this is
important I don't want to do a conan
thing guys oh look at all this oh we got
a lot of gray hair going on oh man okay
let's just go through it this is the
best part of this game bye
like I always play this part of Sam as a
ninja's yeah first of all baby when we
go you know I don't want to have the
blonde leg this is kind of cute I wish I
could grow this kind of hair frankly
like my hair just gets thick like a
q-tip you know hey O'Malley would you
mind dragging that in set box of the
lower-left yeah we could go top not I
hate it I hate the man bun I hate the
top not I'm against it but you know it's
kind of this dad maybe gets it done yeah
this is kind of artistic dad that's true
nobody cares about the dudes in the
corner crowd boy that's us thank you
surly duck yeah we've been doing
Wednesday stream Coco's for about a year
yeah so thanks for joining us from last
year all right here we go we got this
Sinead O'Connor got the M&M hairdo
cornrows not into too wacky
that's a pretty good-looking dad Curly's
kind of cool I'm kind of taking the long
hair frankly well that's it dad no
that's crazy yeah purple hair
all right I get it man yeah oh this is
gonna take long this is my you guys
think this one or like a more suave look
long hair suave which wonder which one
are we doing it's the question
yeah that we got an echo we'll stop
talking for a while echo just gonna
crazy y'all hear an echo or what yeah we
know there's an echo we know there's an
echo now fan of or so mister doesn't
like the color doesn't like this hair
alright fair enough
we don't like the streak I guess that's
kind of a
suave suave swoopy Goku guys you gotta
give me a swab all right I'm seeing I'm
seeing more suave I've seen I've seen
suave all right we're gonna swap right
here we go
eyes man what do we do oh god no I'm not
a to look at this this is kind of a ooh
you know he's left it kind of up to no
good this dead sexy dead yeah up to no
good
aah no I want to do something not super
cartoonish for this dad I kind of like a
dad with like got something it you know
he's got a little fire in him you know
like I like this one I kind of like
cleaned that one's a little sad dad well
you know what maybe sad dad's good this
is pretty good I like I like a you want
to want to kind of a bad dad not too bad
of a dad that's crazy
also what are we doing here who's
playing with this yeah that's insane
what that's a Baltimore dad all right I
like this do you know what this is good
I like this what kind of what color do
you like in it in a dad's eyes we could
have him kind of mash dark purple a blue
white would be like storm pink we're not
making Conan this isn't Conan the tired
son are good what color eyes yeah what
do you guys think I mean I'm kind of
partial like dark purple I mean you just
go classic black white red white Saints
red green pink no green no blue eyes
we're not making we're trying not to
make Cody dark purple all right I'm
going dark purple that's calling to me
all right
we're not making Kony and we're not
gonna make toner because we're gonna
choose a different nose that Conan
doesn't have like something like this
you know there's the Conan schnoz
Conan's got it Conan nose nose broken
when he was a kid I know I kind of like
the little button nose I mean is this
alright mouth alright mouth is big ooh
ooh look at this lucky we got here this
looks like a boring dad whoo that's like
a pouty dad like got em mww we're doing
we're not doing Conan boat we're gonna
inspired this dad tells a lot of dad
puns really up to no good
yeah I know yeah hi son known yes we
denied cone and then subtly or making
Conan hey dad's name not Conan exactly
make it you cone Andy Panda know who
takes care of our YouTube channel not me
perfect for this game and they make puns
anyway I want kind of a naughty dad
which one is like naughty but not like
[ __ ]
I don't want like a [ __ ] dad no I want
kind of a naughty dad but not a [ __ ]
dad what's that like this is a [ __ ]
dad yeah I don't want to hear about this
this dad is like get up do your chores I
don't care about that this dad is up to
no good
yeah this dad I mean it's kind of boring
but Stern but fair this dad maybe we do
this dad I just dad is - autumn all over
yeah
first mouth somebody's saying this one
you're crazy
bottom left mouth no look a third from
left on the bottom looks centered on it
yeah see you know what this dad could
this guy this dad could you know yeah I
like them this dad is gonna let you ride
on the back of a motorcycle but gonna
make you wear your helmet yeah you know
it's kind of a trade on yeah you know
I'm saying I guess the lips don't really
matter but I do like these lips no I
don't like those lips
we shove maybe it matched this is a very
bad dad no all right
Jessica Jones dad all right now brows I
think we got a match I'm sorry we got to
do it it's gonna drive me crazy
otherwise oh look at this ooh wait a
second
Oh this is kind of cool yeah it's kind
of mad I'm liking this dad yeah like a
Kendall he does a little bit I'm making
my changes in the corner bottom like big
ones oh yeah look you changes that there
yeah that's great - yeah right over they
can't see over do we like big brows
little brows I know we're getting deep
oh look at this wait this is look at
this dad this is great
oh you know what we want a dad a little
puppy dog thing we got a little puppy
dog thing I like it I think it matches
the nose and you know what how can you
say no to this dad you know how can you
say no to this dead oh boy now crowd
boys going crazy on the YouTube
situation thank you for your comment
thank you for your comments yeah no this
looks fake I know that we want any
facial hair on this dad honey what you
think I think clean cut man we got a
clean cut dad none of this is doing it
for me I like it yeah yeah I want a
clean cut that no glasses wait a second
we could this could be a really cool
look at this really good-looking dad
here oh yeah we got a good Oh what color
though pink
hey it kind of matches the hair pretty
good isn't good-looking dad check crowd
voices shut up make it look like the
Joker big brows clean dad no beard no
beard I don't know if you looks good
with a smalls - give him a letter in
there it's looking more like Andy we are
kind of making Andy dad
oh my god we're making an Andy dad I
don't know if I dig the glasses now I'm
thinking all I can see is Andy yeah
maybe we should make that hair different
maybe fun people hated the bus people
hate the bun
maybe the long hair that you liked what
not this dead the long hair this one I
don't know people like the longer I
think the long hair people that I don't
have people liked along here
balding dad hashtag relatable to
relatable Counting Crows dad this is
kind of it this is not it's kind of
looking like with the glass a little bit
of a Whoopi Goldberg dad maybe just like
this what about this right this is we
don't want to Zodiac killer Tufte I'm
definitely printing out a picture my dad
for sure and hang it try not st. dad for
one minute but Jesse we're making out
we're building our dead father we're
making our failing switch this sure
their eternal figure no clean-cut crop
hair looks like I'm trashy yeah you're
right
you know when I started second-guessing
myself let's just go back to the suave
I'm sorry guys this is gonna be an hour
of me just going through hairstyles for
our dad alright this is good I like the
glass the glasses are great piercings I
don't know about a piercing man it just
feels like we're better than that
you know we're mature dad we don't want
a piercing oh oh but look at this but I
think I don't know maybe something
understated yeah I like it clean I like
it clean clothing here we go now this is
where we're gonna shine okay nope
this is trying way too hard to be Aaron
Blair a lot of these are me oh wow
that's a great look I'm very I'm very
jealous of all these looks this is great
alright this is the front runner
this is a from our game grumps great
great job with this by the way this is
already awesome this is kind of cool
dude look at this oh my god
this I mean this is the frontrunner for
me right now ya know it's two businesses
no I agree I agree yeah yeah exactly
can't he's not gonna have that hair ever
day okay so we got it narrowed down uh
this doesn't the Tan doesn't work with
our hair any sex bit catsuit one I like
the count one two what do you guys think
catsuit hello from Denmark hello India
catsuit everyone's like in the Katzie
yeah I think we got it man
right and good daddy Oh what should we
name our dead what's our dead name hmm
kitten suit everyone's loving the
kittens all right what's our dad name I
think our last name should be daddy
mm-hmm first name first name what does
he look like he kind of looks like a
chip Reggie Reggie maybe kind of like a
chip okay like oh my gosh it's hi I'm um
Marvin's not bad daddy
Joseph Montgomery chips Montgomery chips
is pretty good Aaron yeah yeah Burt I
kind of like monk Aaron good putty Puff
Daddy yeah daddy's funny cotton Andy
Burt daenerys baby daddy Marvin Zindler
what's the one I just said that I like
[Music]
somebody said yeah what no no no is
Montgomery my gunner eat chips is pretty
good jordan shlonsky
I like Montgomery chips whoever said
Montgomery chips we're going Mike Emery
chips
dumb as bricks on Twitter dumb as bricks
on twitch we're naming you've picked the
name today Montgomery chips right looks
like a Montgomery yeah cuz he's Monty
yeah Monty for sure you know we're gonna
be that dad ready right here do you want
to press the button yeah
yes yeah your parking he'll make sure to
keep your word all right here we go
all right Montgomery Monty chips
Monty chips yes fell so tight oh look at
us we're so good oh yeah oh thanks about
your good job every box is sealed except
for one weight straggler what's in it
looking into the boxes here bunch of old
photos and photo albums whoa I haven't
seen these in years I think it's time
for a little memory lane dusty oh man
we're gonna see a mandamus she was a kid
the only way oh wait no did she have two
dads or dad - mom two dads
let's put the sunglasses on you I'm not
sure kids love sunglasses on pretty cool
all right
Halloween you're four oh that's a great
costume princess dragon that's awesome
all right this is they're going deep in
the story which I appreciate yay speed
ups Monty we time to teach these kids of
discipline - yeah exactly
course phase every girl is a horse phase
right so horsing tainha brave is a good
name all right uh uh superior dad arms
all right blackmail lay down the rubbers
just skip through some of this stuff
it's a bit too deep ready to try me Oh
picture oh we played the ska band that's
cool
Scott meanest manifesto that's a great
name
yes the red horn section it's Emma P no
it's Emma our we didn't mean Emma Pizza
high school I'll never stop mixing those
two up Oh dad dad Amar's be my best
first I was seven give it like a little
bit of effort oh right
Emma P was the one who Oh Emma P was the
one who oh I think she pooped her pants
sir he's a bowler
everybody remembers then Oh No whoops
sorry man it didn't mean to bring that
up and Amanda you know Monty has a
terrible memory yeah I feel like for a
dad you gotta have a better memory dude
bye what's going on dad yet dad tip
number 60 heavy veteran you guys are
just joining us for playing a dream
daddy a dad dating simulator made by
game grumps today tonight on the show we
have whoo Wesley Snipes blade himself is
gonna be here today Louie Anderson love
Louie Ennis an Emmy Award winner by the
way if you're not watching baskets what
are you doing your life Andrew Lynch
there we go the concept of this game
Panda is we're a dad and we're gonna
date other dads we're single dad make
Friday's food poison for the cheesy
tostada blasts from poisoning oh man
Monte's um I love they did put good dad
jokes in here we do a pretty artistic
home I'd say so proud of you though
Amanda reaches deep down the back and
pulled out one last photo oh no wait
that doesn't look at all in any way like
us it's our other dad but I you know
what I played this game a little bit and
I think plot twist I think the other dad
like we might be a widow I'm not sure
all right
or a widower dude this is the day you
were born and to be a surrogate or not I
feel like we'd probably use a surrogate
yeah hey great day you were born
it's kind of a funny story we got no car
accident right there in the hospital
parking lot what does any beige it's a
fender bender of course I was freaking
out a little lady crashed it was
freaking out I didn't know what to do so
I killed her your father
oh man you old white Hannah looks me
directly in the eyes the calmest I've
ever seen him he says he had a bad
that's it's okay it's all gonna be okay
this is tugging at my heartstrings he
was right you know
I yeah oh no see this is gonna be sad uh
this is gonna be sad guys I yeah we're
we're leaving we're leaving the house
and I don't think it's cuz he left
unfortunately you're right there we go
piloted car one last look at the old
house so many memories here how to
believe your father and I bought this
place it was 20 years ago back when I
back when this cat shirt was made I
think I feel like this is a vintage cash
oh you're getting dark I'm into it
though
I shattered the front window playing
catch you've had strong arms oh my god
robotic brakes windows very imaginative
child when I broke the back window she
broke all the windows seems fitting read
command that's coming up I love it
Rick asks how can this tug in your
heartstrings if you don't have a heart
in the first place well it tugs on your
pancreas strings there are other organs
that can tug others you ready we sit in
silence for a moment
I watched my daughter grow up in this
house it will forever hold a place in my
heart but it stings a little to have to
leave it behind I'm ready let's do it
man I watch our old house our old house
disappear in the rearview mirrors so so
what so matter a cool new pad
all right nestled a beautiful scenic
downtown maple Bay our new house
features Oh washer grand honey have you
ever had dirty clothes most of my life
yes we'll worry about that no longer as
our new place features machination that
will not only clean your clothes would
try them directly thereafter and
upper-class luxury like on some clean
clothes there's no longer the hands and
the fat cats upstairs sweetie
this turns into mr. robot anyway it's
also smaller than our last we gotta you
know what we're just a single-parent
household though it's been alright we're
gonna be down we're moving downtown
she's got to learn how to parallel park
this is great great game yes there's
melting ice in the dashboard I'm not
sure what all this is we kind of have on
the dashboard I feel like maybe this is
like old bills yeah
something it looks like there's a mint
just like a loose mint yeah neighborhood
seems pretty quiet chasing a rowdy teens
after lon
Ford said I'd pancreas drinks that
fusion restaurant was delicious
uh yes you could play as a trans dad
that's true glads all kinds of dads
we're playing as kind of a clean-cut
vintage cat wearing purple haired dad
because I think like here's the thing I
think we're clean-cut but like we're
kind of bad you know like we're we're
like a rogue dad cuz we have purple hair
and purple eyebrows by the way like a
very we're fun yeah we're out we're
ready to hit the town we're ready for a
new life new house agenda firstly to
forge a path okay blah blah blah
you're right get some work done and
check the area okay let's just get in
the new house here it is our new house
hey you know what matches our hair it
does and our clothing boom she kicked
the thing down don't break any windows
dude all right
all that karate chopping tuckered me out
ice cream sandwich I need some coffee
ASAP yeah we're good in a new house yeah
couple the old Manges I don't really
like hot coffee but for the sake of
playing this game we'll say that we're
gonna have hot coffee I only drink iced
coffee here we go
growing your own vegetables all right
here we go
copy walked on through the coffee spent
a cute little place in the corner man
this is it such convenient walking
distance for our place yeah I guess
what's wrong why would I go somewhere
else and drink coffee on a couch oh
we're a lazy dad not have to make
awkward eye contact with other people
this dad is me yeah this dad is me I
hate talking to other people unless
they're on the Internet of course
at least when I'm home for some random
guy is gonna come up and sit on the
recliner next to me I don't feel like a
little weird about it because it
technically is not sitting my table
Montee we not too definitely has
intimacy issues oh my god Monty let it
go okay Monty we get it just get a
coffee man yes we're afraid to meet new
people we're gonna fix that oh this is a
hot day hello if the last coffee table
is incredibly weren't inviting vinyl
records line the walls and patrons
lounge around and well-worn in couches
some cool tunes spin on a record player
next to a little stage mat with one T
all right I don't know there are we too
weird for Matt Matt's got like some tats
here that's a great shape yeah well I'm
gonna copy spoon guys how's it going
what's it the name oh it's uh kind of
dumb gets mentioned in this poem I like
he likes poetry and was a good idea at
the time and suppose now it's still a
good idea because the business still
running people ask my question all the
time if staring a rambling I'm sure all
getting more and more uncomfortable the
more I keep talking this guy seems
perfect for us
Monty oh man
don't be nervous Monty what'll it be a
scan the chalkboard menu and immediately
overwhelmed I'll have a oh this is great
these are all been named Scott speedy
black coffee iced Tegan and Sara a chai
oh yeah there we go
nice Tegan and Sara and we've had Tegan
and Sara in here to do stuff for us they
did watch this and they were delightful
so we're gonna go iced tea Gannon Sara
oh he likes us do you see there's hearts
of blue out of him hello dear mrs.
Heller Tommy Holly saw all right Oh
somebody said you sort of put us up on
the upper left to Bali it's fine upper
left is fine
thanks man oh it's a pun Tegan and Sara
this really yeah we know who Tegan and
Sara is dude
you know what I don't need Tegan and
Sara mansplain to me maybe Montgomery
doesn't know I know
Monty knows mati knows what we know we
love Tegan and Sara Monty loves to unit
Sara yeah you're doing the thing you're
mansplaining Matt we don't appreciate it
of a macchiato macchiato DeMarco oh
that's cool instead of I'm back tomorrow
Co yeah game grumps killing the game
started
starting Debbie says I think these two
would get together the pickup line about
local activism is true biggie smalls
Matt you're kind of trying too hard
biggie smalls big or small I should
change that shouldn't I oh this is great
he's cool he's cute I like titties off
man's makin cool bands and you listen to
anyway hey hey Scott was cool once couch
is pretty comfy maybe I come here on our
couch but it's alright
good lumbar support you sink right into
it okay it's comforting on a couch
Amanda nudges me places right next to
our house and that guy seems not a cool
but also just as uncomfortable with
talking other people as you are
mansplaining his life's is John Feder
has totally become friends with them
friends with benefits
I can't meet new people if I always stay
inside and also don't go outside and
also don't talk to people
ah dude get over it i steagle and Sarah
what God Oh Amanda is my dad Montgomery
Monty for short Matt we should just said
Monty chips yeah oh here we go
yes this is great show be in here a lot
you know what let me get your guy's
opinion on something always asking us
our opinion oh I'm nervous
working on your banana bread and recipe
here we go coming for the name for it
well I think we're gonna have to taste
test at first see we're playing the game
Monty you've got this baby although I do
feel overdressed for 10:00 in the
morning in a coffee shop somebody's
talking about a parent and a chameleon
I'm not sure what's happening we're here
oh thank you Joe Peck I need to give
that Brett and Nana bread a taste if you
want us to in free creative labor taught
her well we have trained for this day
just gonna give you guys free banana
bread anyway right yes that I can't
stand on awkward via we are driving me
crazy
this is amazing he's a good cook good
Baker at least it's like a cook at a
baker different things know if you're
good cook can you be a bad Baker yes Wow
I think is more about like knowing how
long bread to rise and it's like
scientifically yeah you need to wait 12
cook is kind of like a pinch of this
well ever play this with Kona I think
you'd be amusing this radar they're not
good enough women for gunner ah maybe
sir on me my place with Conan yeah this
is great
playdates are great any ideas I'm
stumped I think I might be able to give
you dad's band's puns I'll give it a
shot
all right here we go banana bread
Kennedy's alright grateful banana bread
that doesn't make any sense
Oh grateful bread right said banana
bread I like right side been everybody
yeah lots of hearts get them digits bro
strong decisions that's art baby I want
to say baby because I thought it sound
cool but once I said it I realized it
doesn't sound good coming out of my
mouth you know I should just oh my god
Matt this guy is gonna be hard to kiss
he's gonna be like oh but wait thanks
baby
Oh see it sounds good to me you say whoa
look at this across the way a man
catches my eye he sits by himself
brooding over a cup of coffee our eyes
meet just for a moment
there are hot death everywhere hot dad's
everywhere I love this town yeah crazy
sunshine this game is dope I hastily
look away hoping he didn't catch me
staring who is that you finished our
drinks and head out thanks for stopping
in take care of what why are we leaving
uh let's get some fresh air
I'm soaked up all that vitamin D make
our bones nice and strong I do look
pretty pale his gums are gonna get so
strong they're gonna hop right out of
our bodies and crush cars with their
bony fingers I'm and I already have an
irrational fear that my skeleton will
one to escape this flesh sack and run
amok please don't encourage it I love
any game that uses the words flesh sack
yeah you have my money I mean you
already have it cuz I bought this game
but you would have it anyway to the park
that tips 37 don't smoke I will say a
dad deal-breaker for me is if a guy
smokes I'm not gonna date that day
because we know our own kids or his own
kids gonna stroll their neighbor I can't
believe how beautiful it is outside kids
are playing in the street flowers this
place is nice
too nice I don't trust it yeah Marriott
er likes the dark and mysterious dead so
do I can we go back in there and talk to
the mysterious dad scheme EES made by
old people I'm not sure about that the
duties paler than Conan - that's saying
something Ron do you baby walk for a
while and eventually end up in a small
Park toddlers chase each other through
the playground in dogs of all shapes and
sizes romp through the grass it's pretty
crowded but Amanda spots a nice empty
bench we start to make our way over when
heads up whoa what frisbee suddenly hits
me in the face with a neat plaid
handkerchief tied around its neck bounds
up to me wagging its tail what do we say
hello we say hello oh that is so intense
he runs around in a circle and I just my
leg with his nose oh god this is the
cutest dog what do we say can I help you
in part upon me your wisdom or pet the
dog at the dog Beth is just fired from
the hip here
instinct right now well we're gonna run
into dark mysterious dad later ooh Thank
You ELF claw where do I pet the dog
where head rubs give him those head rubs
we need some chin scratches in here do
we try the butt pet corgis like that
ropes the head rubs given the head rubs
he seems to love a good head rub all
smiles here definitely could have caught
that whoa hello guy in white shirt jogs
over us it takes the frisbee from me
it's kind of like he's very manly you
know frisbees are a tradition I caught
the hands on your face oh he's an a-hole
dad tradition got supposed to aim for
people's heads that's too [ __ ] it's a
new technique and I'll catch it with my
teeth next time yeah salty not again not
ever again whoa yeah I like it a little
bit aroused their message idea I'm Brian
by the way I'm Montgomery Monty for
short we should have named him Monty
Monty chips it's my daughter Amanda the
governor made her only to find her
sitting on the ground rubbing the dog's
tummy uh hi your dog's cool uh old
Maxwell sure loves the attention it's
good to see another father and daughter
out here at such a sunny day where's
yours dis everyone of this town have
daughters she's reading a book bigger
than her head she puts it down a heads
overdose well hello Daisy
brothers CaroMont Karma's a gossip how
do you say he's a lumberjack and he's
okay uh oh yeah I saw Kendrick Lamar
last night he was amazing yeah
absolutely
ten she's the precious whoa my natural
dancing kicked in I must brag about my
child's accomplishments time to battle
yes Oh bragging battle this is great all
right go on Daisy tell about yourself
Daisy
um I Brian that's my girl
Montgomery Amanda get in there yeah come
on Amanda Amanda okay okay this is great
I love this game
Oh my knees H look at my knees HP 80
Brian's HP
eighty here we go we're gonna start the
battle what do we do do we brag flee I
don't think we flee no should we use an
item we gotta get you that is a great
card child art spelling bee photo or a
banner we do art she was like smiling
yeah you're right we're gonna hit her
where her weakness you unfurl your
wallet to reveal a tiny copy of a
drawing of a cornucopia Amanda did in
the first grade there we go here we go
blaze my dream daddy I'm not a dad that
I know cute it isn't very impressive but
Amanda genuinely appreciate your head
you're holding on to it
alright 10hp we were gained 20 HP Daisy
just started a weekly chess club at her
elementary school computer lab she's the
president - of course oh [ __ ] dang my
high school doesn't have a chess club or
a computer lab oh no
oh no we're still beating him though we
got 90 because we gained 20 because all
right do we brag
do a quick brag man here just recently
won a local photography award Wow
congratulations yes all right get a
quick hit in I'm doing it wrong what do
you mean moody kiss Oh band-aid he's
butch through the gate grade card onto
her neck like a bull's-eye murdering her
this just made the game a whole lot
better yeah Rick this is awesome
Brian loses ten Daisy looked like she
just wanted DS Lee actually just won a
statewide poetry contest [ __ ] all right
we gotta go big man uh I see you know
what let's use the great card this is
gonna be great right yeah or wait she's
smart too though she's a smart kid [ __ ]
what's this baby photos I don't know
well she takes photos I think
I don't know what's the band-aid but I'm
worried that showing a band-aid would be
like we don't care for our kid yeah no
band-aid no one's saying the brandade
all right no band-aid
oh yeah kill a low and shiny hunter
which is don't worry ban hammers coming
down mostly harmless band-aid is weird
I'm going grade card pull a wrinkled
copy of Amanda's last green card out of
your back pocket we just keep in their
back pocket but we move to a new
allottee yeah we've just yet
Amanda dad awesome grades yes Brian
loses 25 HP yes Brian you really carry
that around everywhere ouch maybe this
kind of weird you lose five feet
whatever right now hold up candy bars is
here to get the top prize I couldn't
knew what a canoe that seems a little
much how's it even possible I mean it
could barely get one of those sticky
hand things it's extra powerful you lose
20 HP oh no a 50th 35 though we're still
winning B photo
really all right pandas saying the B
photo we're going for you ready how much
your phone's browser you managed to pull
up a photo Amanda winning her in 10th
grade spelling bee Brian Wow
congratulations Amanda the easiest
getting prep for annual explain B right
now Brian hopefully this will be her
third win in a row yikes
oh she's won 3,000 I wrote damn it I
mentioned easy Sarah first word at 10
months daddy oh that was man oh no it's
too oh no we're even [ __ ] let's just
brag last week unprompted Amanda helped
an old woman with her grocery bags so
it's extra powerful yes yeah
he's only got 15 HP these here's all of
our adult teeth never had a cavity
either oh who cares
wait oh no what
it's one of their teeth names spelling
bees every year damn it
ah band-aid I don't know about using the
band-aid so we use it
what's DHT our Oh daughter let the
daughter speak Oh maybe yeah oh we can't
switch daughters ha ha that's funny
that's funny oh [ __ ] - that ways to turn
ok we're using the band-aid I'm worried
I don't think the vanity is a good one
all right let's do it band-aid with a
flourish you produce a band-aid for your
pocket take a knee and start to apply it
to Amanda's arm all this is a mistake
Amanda what are you doing dad Montgomery
being protective parent anyone would
agree it's an unusual gesture you lose
10 HP what words on all days he's gonna
buy the way our math is amazing [ __ ]
it's how I actually called her to double
check my numbers where I made a cut for
the support beam did that more than once
dad doesn't that say more about him than
it does about Daisy still he's really
got us beat oh Jesus
we lost call the sack so do we well we
lost guys I should have trusted my
instinct to just had her brag how's it
just like ours slave beer better
landscaped this guy's too competitive I
don't like this guy you know what I
don't think I will but I like your dog
yeah I just want it you know what I want
to get before we hand I just want to get
a little sugar you know I believe you
had a thing for horses shame that didn't
pan out not too late to meieran horse
creative writing too close to the truth
[Laughter]
I'm into chips it's okay not all daddies
are perfect well I guess you're right I
just feel like should we go unpack
we should head now I'm gonna need four
hours minimum to figure how to build my
new bed now I have to sleep on the floor
tonight hopefully well you know what
exactly
all right you got a nice house here I
like the duck I like the photos of our
husband I wonderful a key first visitor
already yeah oh my my wow this looks
like me I'm in the game
hello clean-cut man cookies
Joseph Boone neighbors Montgomery I saw
moving that barracks cookies my daughter
Christie no it's all fathers and
daughters yeah well they're all single
dads Victor that we're playing this on
Steam we're playing this on a pc right
now it's Fred from scooby-doo
yeah it's tennis daddy you're right this
is kind of tennis daddy can you and me
just sprinkled in the chocolate chips
kids right it's nice to meet you just
answer the plate cookies a smile thanks
for the cookies cookies lame what sons
are also tough children is tough yeah
poor kids oh oh we're joking about it
though
oh no we're good mati pull it back dude
is the missus around oh here we go
mister actually an oh he died oh man I
knew it oh this is so sad yeah you know
what grief can bring two people together
I think oh that's so cute he's starting
over right promise that talk about your
dead spouse this time I throw a barbecue
for the cul-de-sac I left me to come by
and meet the rest the neighbors in our
community what do you say pal we'd love
to stop by there we go see look at that
that's great that's very cute they
started over that's great shake hands
and seal the deal
well neighbor I'll see you at 3:00 p.m.
sharp on Saturday I feel like tennis
daddy though to be fair our Joseph
sorry to call you tennis daddy Joseph
it's kind of like Taipei and I feel like
we're not Taipei we need to talk about
stuff I mean I'm the youth master editor
Church down the street well well well
you look pretty young to me but see
yourself ooh you know it's the cat shirt
but that just is gone all right she ate
all the cookies Amanda why do you all
the cookies those cookies go I ate all
those eat all of them anyway just to
make sure that they were not good
religious daddy
exactly
Joseph probably wants his plate back
here we go yes I agree
best neighbors ever we're gonna kick all
their butts yeah I promise have to talk
about your dead spouse this time it's a
lot of pink for a dream daddy that's
true oh we need to make a positive first
impression these kids all look high it
looks super stoned all these kids are so
stoned your dad around they all just
stared as blankly just wanted to return
this nice plate thank you for the
cookies by the way I'll say look at this
there's a big anchor on the house here
what's going on here Jeezy's definitely
Joseph kids they look just like him
where is he I heard they were good and
get to eat any a man to eat all of them
Amanda chips all right set the plate
down on the ground and then walk away
well I hate there I hate his kids so I'm
not hooking up with Joseph it's not
happening yeah it's like the shining
twins I need to rest my eyes nap time
the corn gets the children of the corn
family anyway for what three hours
that's three hours too many time for a
nap alright we're walking on my hair
heavy footsteps come up behind us
Montgomery bro whoa look at this hot
daddy
it's like sporty daddy I turn around and
grab I familiar face Oh Craig
bro bro holy who's Craig it's been too
long dude yeah you look great yeah I
cleaned up my act this is the daddy I
look most like right probably yeah I
said I'm not Asian cleaned up his act
you kidding me he's ripped
I'm Anna's my friend Craig went to
college together were roommates for a
while to Amanda dude you probably don't
remember me but you're so big now hello
and hello cute baby oh thank you honey
about her sizes River say hi River River
river is my kid do every single dad as a
kid in this town
Brad California is relocated the
business back to Maple Bay looks like a
man with a traumatic past bro daddy yeah
this is bro daddy throw away that baby
you got yourself a deal sit we're not
gonna get rid of River
Ashley smashley
oh he's divorced hey there we go that's
all copacetic three kids man bro daddy
take Stan Craig whoa Amanda you know
what a keg stand is you just hit a whole
plate of cookies yeah resistance
training all right this is I don't need
to know a lot about this just move it
along here you know what one of the
great features about this game is fast
forward that's right we're done with bro
daddy weren't gonna get his digits
anyway dude never gonna be putting stuff
right back in these boxes no we're not
moving I mean obviously I'm a
photographer all right that's uh
dude it did it did today it's a letter
from something now she didn't get into
the school she wanted some other schools
gonna want snatch it up for sure oh no
now we got to solve a problem with
Amanda that's true Marriott er says we
already have bro daddy's digits because
you're the college roommates oh there's
a sleepover the poop one but you know
what that means
time for Monty to hit the town yeah we
have plans for tonight and that plan is
going out we are going clubbing by the
way I have on a nice outfit thank you
game here we go all right but I'm not
gonna come pick you up yeah yeah I'm
actually going to go on watch the game
yeah you know the game the ones on today
look I'm getting out of the house for
you what do you want I'll write street
rat head rat oh my god this is very cute
dialog I hate to be I'm just trying to
you know tick tock trying to get to a
little action here all right we gotta
meet some more daddies why have we not
gone to the bar yet never get your and
meeting an English teacher in the
morning all right mr. Vega totally
remembered I'll be there I guess we
can't go crazy then tonight
or can we entirely sure closes bar GP we
are a Deb you don't not ease the GPS
game grumps great job
very detailed you really nailed the dad
thing could it be it's a bar yes Jim and
Kim's bar small and dimly lit the crack
of pool sounds of the back as patrons
laugh and joke a string of multicolored
Christmas lights hover above the
bartender I can't tell you Jimmy can't
pull the seat at the bar what'll it be
one beer please
one beer see some shots man
they got fireball shots here let's do it
I'm Neil Oh fair enough the game what
game is even playing really club mascot
doing cartwheels
oh well whoa whoa hello
hey sailor oh hello maybe fresh meat in
here Jesus yeah I'm watching the game
get out of here a little on the nose a
Mary yeah I get the feeling she's drunk
too no not interested go away maybe some
other time
well well well
see you later see you never sorry not
sorry
predators in this bar I'm just trying to
have a nice simple beer by myself go
team
yes oh dude look he's got a tattoo on
his hand oh this is this is our guy
sipping whiskey he's not drinking a
freakin beer this is a dream daddy right
here mm-hmm
Slayer Darth I got to check out the new
season of Batman must be reading four
different teams my team is far superior
I have to disagree with that blah blah
blah okay quiet Cheers
yes my team wins all right all right
truce for the game
Roberts well hello robber I'm Monty for
shorts I don't know just that hmm Mary
already hit on you yep she's a peach
well you picked the best bar in town as
slimy as it is you'll never find a
better spot than Jimmy Kim's I see Jimmy
Kim I certainly talk when I'm nervous
not enough meals in this world okay I'll
drink most things yeah let's do shots
yes
this dude loves shots bad daddy oh yeah
here we go take the shots the whiskey
burns oh come on that's what making
friends is bro my friend Lee what are we
gonna compliment rugged good looks who
wants a compliment a hand tattoo yeah
Robert is a dream daddy for sure good
dude Monty
got some love there this guy's
mysterious and cool way cooler than I am
Robert signals apart ever another round
what are you doing here tonight trying
to make friends I think yeah put myself
out there hell yeah dude can you be
close I think you don't care about
anything but actually care very deeply
about everything at the point of the
debilitating this guy's kind of cool I
like it actually
you know what I feel like a lot of this
is just an act but he's like a really
good guy
be right back at a pot of my nose never
seen Robert this talkative he must like
you I guess so goddamn it Robert is a
gruff charm comes back from the bathroom
grabs his leather jacket oh man oh
you're heading my way yes oh here we go
every Ollie hot dad's living the same
cul-de-sac spectral he trashes me on
everything so our love can change him
it's a trap oh no are we gonna get
robbed no I believe in love we're not
gonna get mugged Roberts guy he's got a
good heart good neighbors some of them
who's that we got we get to Robert's
house just a few houses away from mine
we stopped he turns to me oh here we go
I don't kiss and tell Montgomery yes
yeah he's direct oh my god uh Maundy we
have a realization what are we even of
course
Monty lay it on smooth are smiling nod I
think just smile nod I'm worried
trying business yeah alright if this is
do graphic we might have to quit this
really close keeps recycling sitar leave
me aside the moment the door closes
behind us he pushes me up against a wall
kisses me grabbing my hips come on our
takes my hand leads me up the stairs
into what I assume is his bedroom so
dark I can't see anything with Roberts
intense expression that means his
apartment is super messy or his house is
super messy cuz he's not turning on the
lights he doesn't want you to see
something
chucking up his jacket clumsily take out
my twos hands oh my gosh what do we tell
you we don't normally do this we had a
husband no don't stop ah that's it fun
about the look oh it's the morning after
that was classy handle a classy way see
I told you his place was messy look at
all those bottles that's why I didn't
want us to see also look at like the
outside this guy's a smoker if I knew
that he was a smoker I wouldn't hook tup
with him so extremes in between the
slats of the blinds my head is pounding
I really overdid it last night wait a
minute this isn't my old house or my new
house oh no did we miss a man the
meeting with Amanda's teacher oh [ __ ]
look around for Robert I find myself
alone let's go through his things fired
from the bathroom in the door opens
Robert is fully dressed and grabs his
keys oh man that's it one nightstand
should go oh no you know what we should
have known that Robert was just a fling
talk to you later
cracks a smile he's just doing it for
the pizza we wanted love the closer over
there hastily you trust show myself the
sun's unbearably bright when I suddenly
remember Amanda no no
oh man that's kind of me you got a
kidnappers gonna have to come rescue you
made a friend at the bar yes that's
great
see it all worked out
oh this is great we got a great daughter
all right guys I think we're gonna end
it for today
thank you for joining us this was super
fun the game is dream daddies a dad
dating simulator by game grumps it's
amazing um you know and we're feeling
pretty good we're pretty tired we got
lucky
although you know what I'm not sure
Roberts the guy for us I feel like yeah
who do you think is the daddy we're
gonna end up with out of all the beds
I like the coffee shop yeah I think Matt
is the best way yeah Matt got us he's
awkward like we are he's not competitive
we don't have history that we're like he
doesn't have a core you know he does not
a core you that super guys by core you
also like the youth minister guys so
like Taipei kids suck uh so yeah we're
gonna try to end up with Matt guys thank
you for joining us make sure to watch
the show tonight we've got the amazing
Wesley Snipes we've got the incredible
Louie Anderson and the unbelievable Tom
Lynch drooling drooling Sean tonight uh
1110 TBS we'll see you guys next
Wednesday for another stream go go see
you guys later bye